양자 컴퓨팅 실전 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 이번 에피소드는 첫 번째이자 종종 가장
어려운 단계인 양자 프로그램 정의에 집중할 거예요. 일반적인 문제를 양자
컴퓨터에서 실행할 수 있는 circuit으로 매핑하는 거죠. 이 단계는 주어진 계산
문제에서 시작한 사용자가 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있도록 변환하는 방법을 설명해요.
이 시리즈의 이전 강의, 2강과 3강에서 매핑 단계가 Qiskit patterns 프레임워크의 첫 번째 단계라고 설명했어요.
그 강의들에서 우리의 목표가 계산 문제를 비용 함수나 기댓값으로 변환하거나
다시 쓰는 것이었다는 게 기억나실 거예요.
그 기댓값을 양자 컴퓨터로 평가할 수 있는 거죠.
3강에서는 max cut이라는 구체적인 예시를 다뤘는데,
계산적으로 어렵고 조합 최적화에서 흔히 볼 수 있는 문제예요.
그 예시에서 초기 그래프를 양자 고유 문제로 변환하는 여러 단계를 거쳤어요.
그래프에서 최대 컷 수를 찾는 문제를 비용 함수로 변환하고, 그 비용 함수를
Hamiltonian으로 다시 썼으며, 기저 상태가
max cut에 해당하는 시험 양자 상태를 준비했어요. 마지막으로 원하는 시험 양자 상태를 나타내는 quantum circuit을 구성하고
상태가 시간에 따라 진화하도록 특정 gate들을 추가했어요. 이 일련의 단계들이 우리가
매핑이라고 부르는 거예요. 큰 그림에서 보면 이 절차는 양자 화학 같은 많은 다른 응용 분야에도
일반적으로 적용돼요. 양자 시뮬레이션도 마찬가지고요. 자, 매핑이 어려울 수 있다는 사실을 외면할 수는 없어요.
모든 단일 문제에 맞는 만능 전략은 없기 때문에 막막할 수 있어요. 오늘은
여러 문제의 대표적인 예시들을 소개하고 각 경우에 어떻게 매핑했는지 설명할 거예요.
Max Cut에서 사용된 것 같은 그래프 문제에 대해 배운 내용을 빠르게 정리하고 나머지 강의는
자연에서 나타나는 문제들, 예를 들면 생물학의 분자 구조 문제, 전자
화학의 구조 문제, 고에너지 물리학의 양자 장론 시뮬레이션에 집중할 거예요.
하지만 이 에피소드의 대부분을 문헌 속 예제 문제들을 살펴보는 데 쓰기 전에, 문제를 매핑할 때
우리가 달성하고 고려하고 싶은 주요 사항들을 큰 그림에서 먼저 보여드리고 싶어요.
quantum circuit으로 변환해야 하는 어떤 유형의 계산 문제에 대해서도 고려해야 할 몇 가지 사항이 있어요.
첫째, 문제를 실행 가능하게 만들기 위해 단순화해야 할 수도 있어요. 이건 대부분의 과학
분야에서 흔한 일이에요. 양자 컴퓨팅에만 국한된 게 아니에요. "구형 소를 가정하라"는
표현을 들어보셨다면, 시스템을 있는 그대로 정확하게 묘사하기 어렵다는 사실을 암시하는 거예요.
대신, 여전히 유용한 해결책으로 이어질 수 있는 합리적인 단순화를 할 수 있어요.
양자 컴퓨팅에서 이렇게 할 수 있는 몇 가지 예시로는 hardware efficient ansatz를 선택하거나 복잡한 시간 진화를 잘라내서 circuit의 크기나 깊이를 제한하거나,
또는 양자 상태의 최종 에너지에 거의 기여하지 않는 Hamiltonian 항들을
무시하는 방법들이 있어요.
다음으로 말씀드리고 싶은 건, 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 방식으로 문제를 작성하는 것에 대해 생각해야 한다는 거예요.
보통 이 세 가지 질문을 던지는 게 필요해요. 첫째, 이 모델에서 우리의 qubit들은
무엇을 나타낼 건가요? 둘째, 우리 문제가 연속적인가요? 양자 컴퓨터는 디지털이기 때문에
문제를 이산화하는 방법을 찾아야 해요. 셋째, 문제의 토폴로지가 하드웨어의 토폴로지와
일치하나요? 맞다면 좋은 거예요. 하지만 그렇지 않다면 작동하게 만들기 위한 몇 가지 트릭이 필요할 수 있어요. 자, 이
첫 번째 질문을 다뤄봐요. 특히 새로운 개념으로서 매핑을 이해하는 데 있어 모든 어려움의 핵심이라고 생각하는 거예요.
qubit은 무엇을 나타낼 수 있을까요?
qubit은 많은 것을 나타내는 데 사용될 수 있어요. 제 생각에 가장 첫 번째이자 가장 간단한 건 그래프의 노드예요. 그래프는
연결성을 나타내는 데 사용되고 다양한 유형의 수학적 문제들에서 쓰여요. 그리고 노드는 네트워크 내의 점이나
개체를 나타내는 기본 요소예요. 전체 네트워크가 무엇을 나타내느냐에 따라 도시, 사람, 또는
격자의 강자성체가 될 수도 있어요. qubit은 또한 보손과 페르미온을 나타내는 데도 사용될 수 있어요. 여기서 주의할 점은
단일 qubit이 보손 하나나 페르미온 하나와 정확히 같지 않다는 거예요. 조금
더 복잡하고 곧 자세히 설명할게요. 하지만 일반적으로 어떤 통계를 따르는 스핀 체인은
qubit 아키텍처로 쉽게 변환될 수 있는 것들이에요.
이제 조금 더 복잡한 예시들로 들어가고 있어요. 이런 모델들의 경우 단일 qubit의 관점에서 얘기하는 건 더 이상
의미가 없어요.
대신, 물리적인 무언가를 구성하기 위해 qubit들의 그룹이 필요해요. 예를 들어,
heavy hexagonal 토폴로지 위에 표현된 qubit 그룹을 아미노산이나
폴리머 사슬의 기하학적 위치를 나타내는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 또 다른 예시는 고에너지 물리학 모델에서 하드론 산란의
시뮬레이션인데, 이건 hadronic 파동 패킷의 시간 진화를 시뮬레이션해서 할 수 있어요. 이 경우,
qubit 레지스터를 양자 장의 다른 상태들을 인코딩하는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 그 장의 진공 상태나
이 진공 위에서 전파하는 파동 패킷 같은 것들이요.
또한 문제를 양자 컴퓨터에 매핑하는 데는 별개의 단계들이 있다는 점도 언급하고 싶어요. 하나는 상태를 qubit과 circuit으로 매핑하는 거고
두 번째는 비용 함수나 양자 관측량과 연산자의 기댓값을
매핑하는 거예요. 구체적인 예시들에서 이것들이 어떻게 처리되는지 볼 거예요. 하지만
지금까지 우리 앞에 놓인 과제에 대해 충분히 추상적으로 이야기했어요.
이제 이 예시들을 자세히 들여다봐요.
첫 번째 예시부터 시작해요. 제 생각에 가장 쉬운 매핑 문제 중 하나는 우리가 이미
어느 정도 자세히 다뤘던 max cut 예시예요. 그 문제에서 매핑은 qubit 하나가
그래프의 노드 하나와 같다는 점에서 꽤 쉬웠어요. 그래프에서 노드를 사용하는 건 매우 직관적이고
다행히 많은 응용 분야에 해당해요. 서로 연결된 노드들의 연속으로 모델링하고 싶은 게 있다면,
0 또는 1이나 집합에 포함 또는 미포함처럼 그룹이 이진수라면
이 노드들을 간단하고 자연스럽게 비트나 qubit으로 매핑할 수 있어요.
이 예시에서, 심지어 에피소드 3에서 100개의 qubit으로 확장했던 것에서도, 그래프 연결성이
이미 초전도 하드웨어의 토폴로지와 일치했어요. 그래서 그 부분에 대해 걱정할 필요가 없었죠. 하지만 항상 그런 건 아니에요.
지금까지 강조했던 예시들보다 더 복잡하거나 연결이 많은 그래프가 있다면
swap gate를 구현해야 해요. 하지만 이건 실제로 transpiler와 관련된 Qiskit patterns의
두 번째 단계에서 처리돼요. max cut 문제의 다른 장점은 우리가
QUBO 공식을 사용해서 비용 함수를 Hamiltonian으로 표현하는 방법을 이미 알고 있다는 거예요.
양자 컴퓨팅과 변분 양자 알고리즘에서 Hamiltonian 비용 함수는
Hamiltonian의 기저 상태에 문제의 최적 해를 인코딩하는 함수예요.
비용 Hamiltonian을 구성하기 위해 Qiskit의 sparse pauli op 클래스를 사용해서
그래프의 연결성을 지정할 수 있었고 양자 연산자로의 매핑 단계가 완료돼요. 그리고 quantum circuit은
그냥 QAOA ansatz였어요. 이게 기억나지 않는다면, 에피소드 3으로 돌아가서
훨씬 더 자세히 설명한 내용을 확인해 보세요. 자, 이제 난이도를 살짝 올려봐요. 다음으로
"단백질 접힘을 위한 자원 효율적인 양자 알고리즘"이라는 논문에서 모델링된 예시를 살펴볼 거예요.
IBM과 뉴사우스웨일스 대학교의 공동 연구예요. 생화학 배경 지식을 조금 알아볼게요. 단백질은
긴 아미노산 사슬로 이루어진 거대 분자예요. 이 긴 사슬들은
다양한 생물학적 기능을 수행하는 복잡한 구조로 접혀요.
3차원 공간에서 단백질 구조를 결정하고 구조와
기능 사이의 관계를 이해하는 건 오늘날 생화학에서 가장 어려운 문제들 중 하나예요.
단백질은 아미노산들 사이의 상호작용 때문에 유용한 구조로 접혀요.
구조가 꼬이고 접히면서, 사슬에서 서로 멀리 떨어진 아미노산들이 바로 옆에
위치하게 되어 강하게 상호작용할 수 있어요. 에너지를 최소화하는 최종 구조를 예측하려면 아미노산들 사이의 모든 상호작용을 설명하는 Hamiltonian이
필요해요. 여기서는 아미노산 사슬과 그것들이 양자 컴퓨터에서 어떻게 모델링될 수 있는지,
그리고 어떻게 아미노산 간 거리를 얻어
상호작용 에너지를 계산할 수 있는지에 집중할 거예요.
이를 통해 실제로 양자 컴퓨터에서 시뮬레이션하기 위해 Hamiltonian에 필요한 모든 기여들을
모을 수 있게 돼요. 실제 단백질에서 아미노산들은 가능한 위치들의 연속체를 차지할 수 있어요.
하지만 여기서는 단순화를 사용해서 각 아미노산이
격자의 한 점을 차지하는 격자 모델로 제한할 거예요. 여기서 저자들은 정사면체 격자를 사용했어요.
여기서 간단히 알아두실 점은 max cut 문제처럼 노드 자체가 아니라 엣지의 방향을 인코딩하고 있다는 거예요.
각 qubit은 정사면체 격자를 따라가는 가능한 한 단계 경로를 나타내요. 인접한 사이트들이
격자에서 방향이 다르기 때문에 이 다이어그램에서 A 또는 B로 표시된 것을 주목하세요.
단백질 사슬은 이 격자에서 일련의 방향 전환이나 방향들로
표현돼요. 아미노산 사이의 각 방향 전환은 네 가지 방향 중 하나일 수 있는데,
정사면체의 엣지들에 해당해요.
이 네 가지 가능한 방향 전환은 네 개의 qubit을 사용해서 인코딩돼요.
조금 복잡하게 들리죠. 이 예시를 좀 더 자세히 살펴봐요.
첫 번째 아미노산 사슬을 정사면체 격자의 이 점에 놓아봐요. 첫 번째에서
두 번째 아미노산 사슬로의 방향은 임의적이에요. 시스템을 항상 회전시켜서 그 엣지가 원하는
방향을 가리키게 만들 수 있으니까요. 그러니 두 번째 아미노산을 여기에 놓아봐요. 보기 조금 어렵지만,
두 번째에서 세 번째로의 경로도 실제로 임의적이에요. 세 가지 선택 모두
두 엣지 사이에 약 109.5°의 각도를 갖게 돼요.
이 두 번째 엣지를 선택하는 건 단순히 공간에서 단백질의 방향을 결정하는 거예요. 그러니 일반성을 전혀 잃지 않고
첫 번째 방향 전환들을 그냥 0 0 1과 0 0 1로 선택할 수 있어요.
0. 이런 단순화를 통해 아미노산 사슬의 구성은 이 표현으로 간단히 나타낼 수 있어요.
지금까지 정사면체 엣지들을 qubit으로 매핑했고 우리의 quantum circuit은 ansatz가 될 거예요. 이제
문제의 에너지를 Hamiltonian으로 인코딩하는 방법을 고려해야 해요. 그래야 기저 상태가 최적의
접힘 패턴을 알려줄 수 있으니까요. 이제 주어진 구성에 대해서 아미노산들 자체의
상호작용으로 인한 관련 에너지가 있을 거예요. 이 상호작용들은 두 아미노산이
서로 가까울 때 가장 강해요. 당연히 사슬의 백본에서 인접한 아미노산들은 항상 서로 상호작용해요.
하지만 단백질이 꼬이고 접힐 수 있기 때문에 다른 아미노산 쌍들도
상호작용할 수 있어요. 예를 들면, 10번과 20번 아미노산이 단백질이 접힌 후에
인접한 자리에 놓일 수 있어요. 서로 가까이 위치하게 된 아미노산들은 더 강한
상호작용을 하면서 접힘 과정을 이끌어요. 하지만 반드시 인덱스가 서로
가까울 필요는 없어요. 그래서 구성 qubit에 인코딩된 정보를 사용해서 아미노산 I와
J 사이의 거리 D를 설명하는 공식이 필요해요. 그래야 분리 거리를 사용해서
그들이 얼마나 강하게 상호작용하는지 결정할 수 있어요. 조금 복잡하지만
따라와 보세요. 꽤 깔끔한 트릭이에요. 먼저, i번째 아미노산이 a방향으로 이동하는지 여부를 나타내는 함수 f sub a of i를 도입해봐요.
i번째 아미노산에서의 방향 전환에 엣지 a가 사용되는지 아닌지를 나타내는 거예요. 여기서 a는
위의 구성 코딩을 고려할 때 네 가지 가능한 방향 중 하나를 취할 수 있어요. 이 함수들을 쓸 수 있고 그러면
인덱스 I부터 J까지 A와 B 격자에서 a 방향 전환 횟수의 차이를
delta N으로 정의할 수 있어요. 왜 이렇게 할까요? 정사면체 격자에
매우 유용한 특성이 있거든요. 여기 이 아미노산에 집중해봐요. 어떤 건지는 상관없지만
E 아미노산이라고 불러봐요. j 아미노산이 얼마나 떨어져 있는지 알고 싶어요. 우리가 가진 건
백본이 이동하는 엣지들뿐이에요. I에서 시작해서 특정 엣지 유형을 따라
중심에서 나가는 한 단계, a 격자 사이트에서 a라고 부르는 엣지를 따라가면
정반대 방향이에요. 그리고 b 사이트에서 엣지 a를 따라 나가는 한 단계로 되돌릴 수 있어요.
따라서 어떤 A 격자 사이트에서든 엣지 A를 따라 여러 단계를 이동하면 E 아미노산에서
백본이 멀어지고 B 사이트에서 엣지 유형 A를 따라가는 단계는
다시 가까워지게 해요. 따라서 A로 표시할 엣지 유형을 따라
아미노산 I와 J 사이의 거리는 A
사이트에서 A 엣지를 따라가는 단계와 B 사이트에서의 단계 차이에 따라 달라져요. A와 B가 단백질
백본에서 반드시 번갈아 나타나기 때문에, 이건 (-1)의 K승 항으로 포착돼요. 이 논리는 다른 엣지 유형에도
적용돼요. 따라서 정사면체 격자 단계에서 아미노산 간의 거리는 결국 이
식으로 계산될 수 있어요. 하지만 아미노산 간 총 거리에 대한 이 긴 방정식에서 어떻게 Hamiltonian을 구할까요?
실제로 정사면체 격자 단계에서의 이 거리들과 유클리드
거리 사이에는 일대일 대응관계가 있어요. 이미 몇 가지 식을 계산해 놓은 게 보일 거예요.
이 거리들은 구성의 에너지를 계산하는 데 사용될 수 있어요.
목적에 따라 쌍이 상호작용하는 것으로 간주하는 컷오프 거리를 설정하거나
더 복잡한 방법을 사용할 수도 있어요. 명확하지 않을 수 있지만, 이렇게 함으로써 실제로 매핑
단계가 완료돼요. qubit의 상태들이 방향 전환을 나타내고, 방향 전환들의 집합이 어떤 아미노산 쌍 사이의
거리를 결정해요. 다양한 아미노산 쌍들은
서로 다른 상호작용을 하는데, 인력도 있고 척력도 있어요. 구성과 거리를 사용해서
알려진 아미노산 상호작용이 켜져 있는지 꺼져 있는지만 판단한다면,
이 강도들은 잘 알려져 있어요. 제가 아는 건 아니지만, 이런 표에서 찾아볼 수 있어요. 요약하자면,
이 예시에서 qubit들은 격자 위의 위치를 표시하는 데 사용되고 이것들이 함께 아미노산 사슬을 형성해요.
그리고 어떻게 구부러지고 접히는지 시뮬레이션함으로써 의학 연구에서 더 나은 결과를 얻을 수 있기를 바라요. 자,
이 Hamiltonian의 몇 가지 항을 계산하는 방법은 건너뛰었는데, 이 문제에 너무 특정적인 내용이었어요. 격자에서
방향을 정의하는 건 더 일반적으로 적용될 수 있거든요.
이제 일반적인 Hamiltonian을 갖게 되면, 항상 양자 컴퓨터 고유의 Pauli 연산자로
변환하고 싶을 거예요. 다음에 그걸 논의할게요.
계속 가봐요. 이제 아원자 입자 시스템을 Pauli 연산자로 변환하는 방법을 살펴봐요. 아원자
입자들은 두 가지 범주로 나뉘어요. 보손과 페르미온이에요. 광자나 힉스 보손 같은 보손은
특정 통계적 규칙을 따르고, 전자나 중성미자 같은 페르미온은 다른 규칙을 따라요.
두 입자의 핵심적인 차이는 보손은 같은 상태를 점유할 수 있다는 거예요. 기저 상태나 다른 들뜬 상태에
얼마나 많은 보손이 있을 수 있는지 제한이 없어요. 반면 페르미온은 이기적이에요. 모든 단일
입자가 자신만의 양자 상태를 가져야 해요. 보손은 또한 정수 스핀을 가지고 페르미온은 스핀 1/2 전자나
더 특이한 스핀 3/2 입자처럼 반정수 스핀을 가져요.
입자 시스템을 설명하려면 에너지에 대한 설명이 필요해요. 페르미온에 집중해봐요. C 연산자라고 부르는 것으로 쓰인
Hamiltonian에서 시작할 수 있어요. 이것들은 기본적으로 시스템의 상태에서 페르미온을
생성하거나 소멸시키는 것에 해당하는 수학적 객체들이에요.
이것들은 종종 fi dagger와 fi로 쓰이고 우리가 이차
양자화라고 부르는 표기법을 사용해요. fi dagger는 상태 i에서 페르미온을 생성하는 연산자예요. fi는
상태 i에서 페르미온을 소멸시키는 연산자예요. 하지만 양자 컴퓨터는 보통 페르미온 시스템을 표현하기 위한 특정 규칙이 있는 qubit
기저에서 작동한다는 걸 기억하세요. 양자 컴퓨터는 본질적으로 페르미온 연산자의
언어로 작동하지 않아요. 이 간격을 메우기 위해, 이차 양자화 표기법을 자연스럽게 quantum gate에 해당하는 Pauli 연산자로
매핑해야 해요.
페르미온에 대한 여러 가지 변환들이 있어요. 일반적인 선택은 Jordan-Wigner 변환이에요.
Bravyi-Kitaev와 parity 매핑은 페르미온 인코딩에서 더 최근의 방법들이에요.
반면 보손 연산들은 Holstein-Primakoff 변환을 사용하거나 직접
Fock 상태들을 사용 가능한 보손 모드의 서브베이시스로 매핑해서 변환할 수 있어요.
보손에 대한 다른 옵션들도 있어요. 다른 인코딩들도 활발하게 연구되고 있고요. 하지만 지금은
Jordan-Wigner 변환에만 집중할 거예요.
그럼 왜 각 전자를 나타내는 qubit을 하나씩 할당하지 않을까요? 할 수 없기 때문이에요.
qubit은 구별 가능하지만 전자는 그렇지 않아요. 예를 들어, 어떤 기기에서든 개별 qubit을 쉽게 표시하고 식별할 수 있지만,
전자의 구별 불가능성은 전혀 표시할 수 없다는 걸 의미해요. 실제로는 특정 전자가 아닌
1s, 2s, 2p 같은 점유 오비탈에 따라 연산자에
표시해야 해요. 따라서 특정 전자에 표시하는 대신 1s,
2s, 2p 같은 점유 오비탈에 따라 연산자에 실제로 표시해야 해요. 그래서 각 qubit은
분자에서 오비탈의 역할을 대략적으로 하는데, 점유 또는 비점유 상태예요.
하지만 그걸 어떻게 하는지는 실제로 좀 더 복잡해요. 그래서 이제 전체 페르미온 시스템의 올바른 통계를
반대칭성을 추적하고 지켜지도록 보장하기 위해 Jordan-Wigner 매핑이라는 것을 도입해요.
Jordan-Wigner 매핑은 오비탈과 qubit 사이의 일대일 대응 때문에 개념적으로 간단해요.
parity 매핑을 포함해 비슷한 목적을 달성하는 다른 매핑들도 있어요.
상태의 parity를 계산하려면 여러 qubit을 고려해야 해요. parity 매핑과 다른 일부 매핑에서는
하나의 qubit이 하나의 오비탈에 해당한다는 해석이 성립하지 않아요.
이제 이 변환을 이해했는지 확인하기 위해 꽤 간단한 예시를 함께 살펴봐요.
단일 qubit 상호작용 f dagger f를 계산하고 싶다고 가정해봐요. 생성 및 소멸
연산자의 정의를 대입하는 것부터 시작해요. 그 다음 항들을 묶어서 항등 행렬 I와 1/4을 인수 분해할 수 있어요.
보시다시피, 교환 관계를 다뤄본 분들에게 익숙해 보이는 항들이 남아요. 여기
괄호 안의 이 항은 다름 아닌 x not과 y의 교환자에 i를 곱한 거예요. 그리고
꺼내놓은 항등식도 잊지 마세요.
이것들은 그냥 Pauli 행렬이라는 걸 기억하세요. 따라서 교환자는 잘 알려져 있어요. 그 순서로 x와 y의
교환자는 간단해요. 2iz예요. 부호를 잃지 않도록 주의하면 이게 최종
결과로 나와요. 결국 페르미온 표현을 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는
Pauli 연산자로 성공적으로 재작성했어요.
Qiskit에서 Jordan-Wigner 매핑을 어떻게 구현할지 빠르게 이야기해봐요. 매핑과 유사한 변환들이 어떻게 작동하는지
이해하고 적어도 한 번은 작동하는 걸 보는 게 중요하다고 생각하지만,
매번 이 모든 계산을 수동으로 하고 싶지는 않을 거예요.
특히 규모가 큰 시스템의 경우, Qiskit의 sparse pauli op 함수를 활용해서
매핑에서 관련 Pauli 연산들을 쉽게 생성할 수 있어요. 최적화되지 않은
구현은 중첩 루프를 사용하고 약 20줄의 코드가 필요해요.
여러분이 탐색할 수 있도록 코드 링크를 여기에 걸어둘게요. 하지만 큰 그림에서 보면 단계는 다음과 같아요.
첫째, sparse pauli ops from list 함수를 사용해서 매핑할 매개변수 공간의
크기에 해당하는 항등 연산자를 생성해요. 둘째, 앞서 보여드린 생성 및
소멸 연산자의 정의에 따라, sparse pauli ops from list 함수를 사용해서 x, y, z Pauli
연산들을 정의해요. 이렇게 하면 페르미온 생성 및 소멸 연산자를 qubit 스핀 연산자로 매핑하고 페르미온
점유 수를 qubit의 계산 기저로 인코딩해요. 그리고 셋째, 위의 연산자들을 관심 오비탈에 적용해서 원하는
Hamiltonian을 Pauli 기저로 생성해요. 이는 보통 핵심인 비상호작용 오비탈을 나타내는 항등 행렬을
생성하고, 그 다음 현재 문제의 특성에 해당하는 가중치와 함께 활성 공간에
생성 및 소멸 연산자를 적용하는 것에 해당해요. 말씀드린 것처럼, 이건 단지 큰 그림 설명이에요. 하지만 코드가
그다지 복잡하지 않아요. 이제 다른 관심 문제들에 맞게 적응시킬 수 있는 자신감이
생기셨을 거예요.
Jordan-Wigner 매핑 방식을 완전히 이해했으니, 더 복잡한 설정에서 실제로 어떻게 작동하는지 볼게요.
이전 에피소드에서 본 하드론 동역학에 관한 논문도 기억하실 거예요. 논문을 다시 자세히 설명하지는 않을 거지만,
놓쳤고 궁금하다면 이전 에피소드를 확인해 보세요. 이 예시에서 Jordan-Wigner 매핑은
전기장이 없을 때 L개의 격자 사이트를 가진 Schwinger 모델의 Hamiltonian을 표현하는 데 사용돼요. 여기서
qubit 하나가 이 모델에서 무엇을 나타내는지 정확히 찾아내기가 훨씬 어려운데, qubit들의
집합 전체가 함께 물리적인 무언가를 만들기 때문이에요. 이 맥락에서는 파동 패킷이에요. 대신,
qubit들을 이산화된 공간 조각으로 대략적으로 생각할 수 있어요. 여기서 L은 각 원소 또는
단위 셀이 두 개의 qubit으로 구성되는 격자 부피예요. 이전 슬라이드에서 봤던 페르미온 연산자들은
특정 사이트에서 파동 함수의 진폭을 설명해요.
따라서 Hamiltonian에는 이 페르미온 생성 및 소멸 연산자들이 포함돼요. 하지만 이런
Hamiltonian을 양자 컴퓨터에 구현하려면 페르미온 연산자가 아닌 스핀 연산자로 표현해야 해요.
그래서 Jordan-Wigner 변환을 사용해요. Jordan-Wigner 변환을 적용하면 새로운
Hamiltonian이 슬라이드 하단의 이 방정식이 되는데, 여기서 sigma plus는 Pauli 연산자 X + IY이고 sigma
minus는 X - IY예요. 이 형식으로 쓰인 Hamiltonian을 갖게 되면
매핑 단계의 어려운 부분은 끝나고 이제 Pauli 연산자로 circuit에 쉽게 쓸 수 있어요.
요약하자면, 최근 양자 컴퓨팅 분야에서 특정 매핑 기법들이 어떻게 사용됐는지에 대한 네 가지 예시를 이야기했어요.
가장 간단한 것부터 시작해서 Jordan-Wigner 변환을 하드론 동역학에 적용하는 것까지 올라왔어요.
이게 많다는 거 알아요. 이 내용은 매우 기술적이고
전에 본 적이 없다면 매우 막막할 수 있어요. 좋은 소식은 연습에 시간을 더 쏟을수록 더 쉬워지고
더 익숙해진다고 약속할게요. 그게 진짜 핵심이고 제가 이 시리즈 전체를
Quantum Computing in Practice라고 이름 지은 이유예요.
이건 누구나 처음부터 바로 잡아서 달릴 수 있는 게 아니에요. 공부가 필요하고
머리를 쥐어뜯는 순간도 있고 아마 좌절스러운 시간도 있을 거예요. 하지만 그 불편함과 함께 앉아서
계속하면서 생기는 질문들을 정말로 탐구해 보길 권해요. 진정으로 배우는 유일한 방법이니까요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요. Quantum Computing in Practice의 에피소드 5였어요. 다음에는 처음부터 Hamiltonian을 시뮬레이션하는 방법을 살펴볼 거예요.
곧 뵐게요.